11 million kilometers from Earth the
spacecraft hurdled closer and closer to
the rocky asteroid that was its Target
and then bullseye
[Music]
scientists and engineers at Mission
Control cheer as the spacecraft smashes
into a far-off asteroid called dimorphos
it's a key step toward defending the
world from future devastating impacts by
Massive space rocks we are showing that
planetary defense is a global Endeavor
and it is very possible to save our
planet
NASA's double asteroid redirection test
or Dart was launched in November last
year its entire mission was to Ram into
dimorphos at a speed of more than six
kilometers per second or 3600 kilometers
an hour the result it's hoped a gentle
nudge pushing the asteroid On A New Path
over many years the change in trajectory
will grow larger while dimorphos itself
is not on a course to collide with Earth
space rocks like the one that flashed
across the sky in Russia nine years ago
hit the planet all the time and the big
ones can change the course of life on
Earth 65 million years ago a huge object
crashed near the Yucatan Peninsula
causing Global Devastation scientists
believe the impact is directly linked to
the extinction of the dinosaurs getting
rid of T-Rex and their kin was a good
thing for us mammals but another
Collision of the same magnitude won't be
it could destroy us all so the
international Consortium behind Dart
hopes to defend the Earth from potential
catastrophe by combining careful
observations to identify asteroid
threats years or decades ahead of time
along with the ability to knock them off
their collision course there are no
known asteroid threats but when we find
one in the future maybe we'll have the
Technologies to potentially prevent it
dimorphos's new trajectory will be
studied for years to come the
information gleaned from the test will
hopefully help prevent Humanity from
suffering the same fate as the dinosaurs
Rob Reynolds Al Jazeera